do you think we're going to get
immortality within our lifetime cuz like
I I don't know because I mean he's going
to get a f yeah yeah yeah I'm like if
anyone's going to outlive anyone it's
going to be Mudan not immortality they
might the daging deing is what I really
bro you're not Immortal so you get if
you get hit by a [__] truck you let's
see how mortal you are don't get hit by
truck okay D doesn't Japan have like the
highest age like yes anymore it's Hong
Kong now oh was it Hong Kong [__] but
how did they do it did he just drink the
little bottles
yeah I think just the diet right the
diet like the average Japanese person
just doesn't have a [__] Diet also
just naturally I think a lot of Japanese
foods are just standardized to be more
healthier than other like cuisines in
the world they do have one of the
highest rates of or higher rate of
stomach cancer because of all the salt
they generally use so just your
salt um I think it's just genetic diff I
don't think it's a genetic diff you
think you don't think it's genetic diff
no I think I think it's diet all diet
it's it's probably diet I mean there
might be some genetic stuff I feel like
genetics has okay you're going to have a
awful
time I like looking at me being like oh
for [__] sake when I'm when I'm at a r
and they give me half of these Foods I'm
like yeah no [__] I'm going to be
immortal if I eat all this I'm like not
I don't know what half of this [__] is
and half of it is slimy and I feel like
it tastes healthy I'm pretty sure you
can get every vitamin from the oh
absolutely absolutely yeah like is Super
Foods a thing yes or is it just like yes
yes but the problem is let me ince you
to broccoli gone and kale they have
superfoods the problem with Super Foods
super cuz they have insane benefits to
the human body do they uh I I assume so
let fact check this like the only reason
like wake me up when we have Ultra Foods
man when are they coming out yeah
where's the next level from Super I want
an Ultra Food you know then like people
then people like they're like oh kale
superfood let me blend it and then it
somehow Lo is all like a bunch of its
traits that allow it to be absorbed into
your body oh yeah isn't that the same
thing with like fruit as well yeah
smoothies too if you blend them um it's
not as not I don't know what the
blending process does where all the
vitamins are just like see you it's like
when you fry something or when you grill
something it's like you know some foods
become a lot less healthy when you grill
or fry them like the problem I find with
a lot of these like you know health
benefits kind of things is that like how
much research has actually gone into it
cuz I swear to God you know sometimes
I'll see like a a video or an article
being like I recommend this diet or I
recommend these kinds of foods and then
someone will come out and say actually
that's not as effective as this kind of
thing and then you get to the point
where you're like actually this is bad
for your body you know and and you just
like I get to a point where I'm like I
don't even know what to [__] trust no
my my favorites are the ones where like
these like food researchers like try to
kind of create a uh create like a middle
ground of being like all right we get
you guys want to eat french fries
so we're going to release an article I
remember I saw this [__] five french
fry like Harvard professors recommend
five french fries a day it's like ain't
nobody eating five fries a day you can
eat [__] food but I think the general
consensus is hey just eat less eat the
amount of calories your body needs and
generally eat uh grains or not grains
sorry um like whole grains or like veg
or you know stuff that are high that are
good for you you can eat the bad things
just eat the things that are good for
you too don't just drink [__] Dr
Pepper and Nuggets you you know what the
biggest [__] lie I think is that I'm
going to just say I've got feeling what
n out of 10 doctors recommend this
product I'm like where where where are
the 10 doctors no my other question ask
who is asking the 10 doctors here no my
other question is who's the one doctor
they didn't recommend
it no because obviously if they say 10
out of 10 doctors recommend this
everyone's going to be like [__] you
say n out of 10 like w well even n out
of 10 I'm kind of like [__] n out of
10 doctors that are on our payroll that
we paid to do the research for this
product uh recommend our product by the
way well I don't think it's working
anymore more that's why they're like
these YouTubers recommend our
products n out of 10 YouTubers recommend
this product yeah cuz like I this is
going to be total [__] because like
you know the whole [__] why do
Japanese people age better I don't I
don't know if anyone really knows is the
Japanese know it's just like we're
guessing that it's diet you know it
might just be genetics it might it might
could be [__] anything I don't
[__] know yeah I really don't know
yeah but you know I don't know how much
actual study or research has gone into
this or if it's just like you know if
it's like a
scientifically back study that has been
like approved by a lot of scientists or
is it just like or is it just like one
independent study to be like just be
healthier try better have better try
better yeah yeah problem is though like
you want to apply a lot of these things
to your life but you only get one
[__] chance if you [__] up you read
the wrong article you're
[__] many articles like 10 years later
they look back and it's like yeah that
was actually very bad exactly right I I
I remember vividly when I was in school
um like there was this like article in
in Australia or maybe the wall I don't
know but I remember in school there was
this article which was just like oh
scientists have concluded that uh boiled
eggs are actually bad for you and it was
just this entire article about that
people were like well [__] I got to cook
eggs in a different way literally 2
weeks later it was just like actually
they're good for you so it's just like
what do you want like do you want to Ste
them or they used to have smokes with
fiberglass filter and that was suppos to
the British with
spos they used to sell menthol
cigarettes with asbestos lining which
is which which okay okay which is [__] F
hit me out hit me out that's life speed
run if you survived that and you live
till 80 you just built [__] Biff yeah
they need to do research on you like he
smoked asbestos all his life and he's
still somehow alive yeah I'm not
stressing too much about it I I I'll
just let my I'll let nature run its
course is there like a is there like an
age you want to get to like like like a
goal age where you're like it you know
it'd be pretty cool if I I just don't
want to be taken care of yeah I'm the
same yeah so whatever age that is just
living like the last 30 years like yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly I just want to
have like an off switch uh you know
that's I know what it's called but you
know you want you want a game end okay
that's that's the I'm not going to go
that gamer
guys you
should I think the game is called it
sding but in in in the perfect world uh
I would just like you know I would just
like to have to a point where my body
just stops working and then it just like
shuts down that's a heart attack yeah
you're describing a stroke a heart
attack uh a bunch of other diseases can
do this too would you would you ever
want to get to the point though like
we've all watched futur right yeah yeah
you know in like Futurama they have like
all the heads would you ever want to get
to that point sounds how good the new
Apple Vision Pro is
on [__] it I don't know well I mean they
got to get rid of this thing right yeah
how can you jack off just you you you w
have the urch they'll never be an Ur to
jack off that
sucks I live dayto day with the
knowledge of knowing that I'm going to
have a great session of jacking off okay
there there's a few like I'll be like as
AE I'll be like Siri play the video
where the guy goes banss and I'll just
watch it on like abolute forever it's
and and like you wouldn't be able to
enjoy a meal like ever again but imagine
how much editing you can get done that's
true imagine the video games and Anime
you could get as a head as a sentient
head mud's like enjoying a meal nah
editing the new trash taste special in
my mind with my eyes okay now I'm now
I'm getting
excited you ever felt like man I got a
problem I like editing too much that was
like seven years ago I accepted it now
oh I'm like I'm at like second
step what's what's the second step I
acceptance that's the final step wait
you have to like do something about it
after step good then yeah no no there
there's more steps where you you
overcome I'm good I'm here I'm
good he's achieved his goal all right
fair enough fair enough
what' you like to do in your
downtime [__] please tell me you
have please tell me you have downtime
let me rephrase the question for forun
do you have downtime uh I mean yeah sure
uh how much do you want I don't know
what what do you like to do when you're
like I don't have anything to do
urgently I can kind of get to whatever
or when you're on holiday I mean I
assume you're on holiday right now right
he's editing this video in his mind as
it's being filmed man the first first
two days here I was in the office trying
to get the new uh episode
out Christ we're so sorry but I I pretty
much picked up streaming just for that
reason so I could do new stuff so like
half their Hobbies I do through streams
so it's like combination of things right
so you you you're the same as Connor
where you're like you you find streaming
is like it's fun man it's fun I really
like it it's fun having an audience to
like just do dumb [__] with fair enough
just test ideas I don't think God and I
are in that
camp I'm like on please take a holiday
no we're telling you to take you were
telling you to take a I'm not an
employee I'm a
freelancer you have no control over my
health I'm eating vitamins damn it I
need to say go quick piss all right all
right all right do something funny for
the patreon
man no